hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly chachar every tuesday
at two p.m. pacific right here on
gamespot com I mean host on you are
joined by mr. Justin hey walls howdy
howdy hey deal my friend doing good
there's a lot of news this week so there
is so join you guys what better person
to come on to tell us all about that
stuff and of course alexa ray corriea
how you doing hey I'm good are you doing
I'm doing fantastic yeah I'm doing
better because I heard that a game that
might have gone missing the last
guardian looked like the trademark was
getting Sony hadn't like updated the
trademark and but then that seems that
that might be a clerical error I'm did
you ever think that it would actually be
going away like it well yeah yes point
after e3 last year when they didn't show
it off because everyone said oh they're
showing it off this year like all the
work whispers in the industry said it's
definitely gonna nada and then I thought
you know uh maybe not and you produced a
great video last week with Mary a
bearish sort of games that have dropped
off our radar I did um yeah there are a
lot of them that have dropped off our
radar actually the last guardian was not
included but they include things like I
think people forgot that there's a new
gears of war and development and cliff
bleszinski Project Blue Streak I think
we're going to hear more about that at
GDC he has a panel the shin megami
tensei Fire Emblem crossover the new
crackdown the new phantom does the new
mirrors edge there's a lot of things
that have sort of been announced and
then gone by the wayside long stretches
cyberpunk 2077 yep The Witcher 3 guys
like where is that game that was a
really good trailer that was an awesome
yeah for something we've not seen
anything else up I guess they're
probably got their hands full at the
moment with with the witcher couple of
months and the last guardian it is kind
of a weird case because i remember when
i almost when i first started in the
video games like back in two thousand
eight that was something that was
announced and you know every year
they've renewed the trademark and so a
lot of people were scared for the less
guardian because suddenly Sony didn't
renew the trademark and it's something
we haven't heard about for such a long
time they're like well guess I mean dis
cancel the Sun is like not out of its we
we assure you still a development but
that's literally all we've heard like
the past three years is we haven't seen
anything new it's just in development is
way that the
Fumito wait out who has worked on the
gate who's worked with that studio for
such a long time it is the creative
vision behind it his basically said you
know I've done yeah I contributed what I
needed to to that game and I'm out so
now we're just like is we assume it's
going to be a ps4 game but literally
nothing so is that not a massive worry
that like the clouds like the reason
people were industry interested in the
last garden was because of the
development clamp behind it and then it
just seems like maybe now they have this
name that has such an attachment to it
that they're just going to push out
something like years later that won't
actually have anything to do the like
creative like like seeds that are first
started from I knew it would be such a
an interesting story to be behind the
scenes and just like to see the drama
that that must be going on there like
that has to be really great like I mean
stretched out now probably probably not
like day today is probably really boring
but like if you were able to condense it
now if you were to be able to do one of
those behind the scenes things but that
that happens to a lot of games sometimes
it really hurts them you know like a
Duke Nukem yeah absolutely long time for
that and switching so many studios were
Sony for them they've kept this a lot
more under wraps like we really don't
know what's going on we haven't seen it
in different versions we don't know what
those changes have been so I mean it
could be any number of problems that
that have kept it from coming out but it
could also be because they're trying to
to find the best way to bring it out or
maybe like what they came what they were
coming up with for ps3 didn't really
translate over to ps4 yeah it could be
really good now maybe well hopefully we
find ever next five months or so with
GDC coming up in a couple of weeks III
though is when obviously we see so many
new game enhancements last year there
was absolutely tons of them as some
we've not heard of since like I think it
games like phantom dust scalebound
crackdown they've mentioned them I know
that a one of the Microsoft producers
has like gone on a couple podcasts and
been like oh like you're gonna find out
where d3 or like scalebound is going to
be like a 60-hour RPG but we haven't
really really know what scalebound is
yet yeah and we don't really know what
the new crackdown is yet we just have
that trailer same with the Phantom
distribute so I think III will be big
for those three like Microsoft is going
to give us everything we want or they
can give right now for those three
surely some sort of years the new gears
maybe maybe because they release an
update last year where rod fergusson
showed like a concept art that was
blurred out so we know that they're
working on it maybe we'll get like an
announcement that'd be nice now that the
xbox one's doing fairly well I think now
would be a good time to announce it um
and that kind of thing doesn't mean that
those are in trouble I mean we in the
same way that movies like those you'll
see a trailer for something at comic-con
in that just means that you know they're
teasing it they're working on it you
really don't want to hear too much more
about it like sometimes seeing too much
can set of expectations or things can
change yeah I got a really good example
is bioshock infinite where we saw a lot
of that game in the lead-up yeah and a
lot of that isn't didn't get into the
final you watch that first trailer now
it's like it's so far removed from what
actually came out yeah they weren't able
to use those ideas like or they had to
use them in different ways you have to
scale back coming because of the reality
of making these games on these huge
budgets and last week as well we heard
about as something else that's going to
be happening at e3 that I'm very very
excited about which is that Bethesda
Softworks are going to be having their
own lil Ubisoft EA style show and tell
and what games do you think might come
up in that it's gotta be fallout 4 this
is their first ever press conference
it's got to be fallout 4 we've have the
new doom that's in development right now
probably see more of that yes I was like
they showed that quakecon it was last
year there was yet he's only people in
the room saw it though so no one outside
of theirs yeah and I think I'm gonna
jump out on a limb and say that we're
going to see another Dishonored yeah at
the summit a good show maybe a wet to
the hot franchise wet maybe those are
the things you want to bring out when
you're gonna do your own conference but
do you think they're gonna do a full
conference do you think would be you
know going the route of Nintendo and
doing a kind of co-direct thing yeah
could be cool too I think they have the
the amount of like what Bethesda is now
is like they're just publishing so much
stuff that they have enough fans to like
fill out a room and like say that this
is everything we have like if you be
self can do right now I think like
Bethesda are in a good place to do it as
well I'm kind of with you I'm I don't
think they can do that without
announcing fallout 4 and like the amount
of ramp like rumblings about it last
year myself a 90 put out a video last
year saying like it's definitely gonna
be at e3 this year like there's too many
people talking about it
and then nothing and like I was
absolutely gutted but they're still like
those voices are so saying like what's
what's that team what's the Skyrim team
been working on since sound like they
have to work on something and the good
money's on for that right this has to be
it mmm or it could be a collectible card
game you know follow that but it'll be
matched three and you'll have like
little fallout heads and I guess we'll
have to wait and see and III is on a
couple of months GDC though is on in a
couple of weeks that seems to be the
time of year when all those secrets like
start to come out yeah there's a lot of
drinking a GCC is not is not an e3 level
conference that is it is the game
developers conference traditionally it's
always been for game developers but more
and more it is a place where people are
showing off new stuff and we know a lot
of things like they've been very public
with some stuff that's going to be at
the show Steve's gonna be showing off
new steam machines microsoft said
they're gonna have a big presence like
they're going to be games there which is
that someone in some ways takes away
from the spirit of what GDC is about but
yeah it's really exciting for us like
especially since it's right down the
road it's right next to us and a lot of
people hang out there's a lot of game
developers and not all of them are you
know as as good with keeping secrets
yeah some others sometimes you just
walking around and I'll just be talking
about oh yeah follow up five is totally
this awesome game w bar did it go camp
out in the WR the doll really yeah
that's redic that's where everyone goes
to leak their secrets there you go if so
if you're in the san francisco area or
in early march head to the w bar and
then you won't have to listen to
gamespot talk anymore i can just get it
all from the source right there and let
us know what you think about the last
guardian some of those other games that
we might see in 2015 in the comments
below